I remember watching him Rudy and being
like this guy just wasted his time he
wasted his [ __ ] time what was the
promise of Rudy again what'd they do
that walked on the notre-dame and got in
for like one played the end of his
career and it's like yo if he didn't get
a movie made about him like that was a
huge waste of his time worked out got it
he got to be in shape for a few years
shape got doesn't go to some parties and
a lot of t-shirts and gear went on a
writer in that movie no no I'm thinking
of a different one then you think it a
Girl Interrupted Winona Ryder like his
beetlejuice no she was in the movie Oh
Lucas she was in that movie where I
can't
and again another thing a nerd trying to
do some [ __ ] for girl he got lit up
coming across the middle as he should
have cuz he shouldn't been on the
[ __ ] field if you're not built to
play football don't go out there cuz
you're trying to get some puss so I'm
glad I got lit up by the one sack he did
have and stop trying to overachieve to
get some puss let's go make money give
money girls will come around it doesn't
matter you have to play football you
dumb [ __ ]